ChatGPT today has incredible capabilities. It is
like an engineer who helps you write a video game,
it is like a scholar who helps you write a paper,
and it is like an assistant who
organizes your life, and files.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, large language model assistants understand
text and they understand images. They have for
quite a while now. However, connecting
the two still remains a challenge. But,
with GPT-4’s vision model, we can dump
all this information into a robot,
and it will be able to take commands from us, and
make a plan and perform it. And it gets better,
it promises that it also has some common sense.
Something that is not common at all in today’s
world. So can it deliver these promises?
Let’s see together through 3 experiments.
Experiment 1. Here, we would like to get some
coke, but, look. Haha! There is no coke anywhere
to be seen. Now’s your time to shine, little AI,
and then, nice. It opens the fridge very gently,
gets the coke, closes the fridge, and
there we go. Excellent. It can also do
similar other gentle tasks, such as get
some pringles and pour it onto a plate.
Experiment 2. Pick up the marvel model. It is,
of course, behind a strategically placed glass.
And without additional instructions, it puts
it away safely, and now we can play. Great!
Now experiment 3. This is a bit harder perhaps.
Organize the sushi pieces to be like they are in
this image. A tricky, multi-modal question.
Can it do it? Oh yes, well done little AI!
Now two good news and one bad news.
Good news number one, yes! This one
is also doing one of my favorites,
and that is, learning safely
in a computer simulation first,
and only when it demonstrated that it is smart
and safe, can it move around in the real world.
Good news number two - this can perform all of
these tasks in a zero-shot manner. This means
that it can perform a broad spectrum of these
everyday tasks without being specifically trained
for it. What does that mean exactly? Well, if
you give it a task that it hasn’t seen before,
it can lean on its knowledge of the world a
bit like a human would and have a good chance
of still being able to do it. If you ask me,
that is one possible definition of intelligence.
Now, less good news - not even this
technique is perfect. Look. Chain of
thought. This means that with the prompts, it
gets a little help. At the risk of simplifying,
this help comes in the form of a few
exemplars that outlines the reasoning
process for a few tasks for the AI
to lean on. It’s not that bad. And
I bet that just one more paper down the
line, and this might not even be needed.
But today, ChatGPT can do so much more. For
instance, here it helps this Fellow Scholar
write a video game without the user having to
write a single line of code. First, we need to
briefly describe the game. And it gets to work,
and then, the first version is already playable!
Excellent! Wait, the missiles are not exploding,
so, is the dream over? Of course not! Look,
after taking a couple screenshots of the game,
don’t forget, GPT is multimodal, it can look at
images, and then, we can explain the issues,
we need some explosions, collision detection,
and. Look at that! A significantly better game in
a matter of seconds. Explosions are now happening,
now add a scoreboard to the game, a start screen,
and a damage/health system. It explains what it
is about to do, and there we go. A proper
little arcade game. This is like having
a super fast, super smart engineer at your
fingertips. This is absolutely incredible.
But this is not only an engineer, but
it can explain mathematical jokes.
This is one of my favorites. This one is
about explaining the difference between
discrete and continuous mathematics. Love it.
But wait, it’s not only good for explaining
mathematical jokes, but also for doing mathematics
and writing papers. Take this from one of the best
mathematicians in the world today, Terence Tao.
Even he is using GPT-4 too and he says as follows:
“I could feed GPT-4 the first few PDF pages of
a recent math preprint and get it to generate a
half-dozen intelligent questions that an expert
attending a talk on the preprint could ask.”
“I plan to use variants of such prompts to prepare
my future presentations or to begin
reading a technically complex paper.”
Whoa! One of the finest mathematicians
of our generation is asking it for help,
and gets meaningful questions and sometimes
answers. But…wait a second. Does that not
sound like a helpful colleague
or a co-author to you? Well,
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because here comes the bombshell:
“When integrated with tools such as
formal proof verifiers, internet search,
and symbolic math packages, I expect,
say, 2026-level AI, when used properly,
will be a trustworthy co-author in mathematical
research, and in many other fields as well.”
Wow.
And we are not done yet, not even close! I
have one more amazing application for you.
It can also take a bunch of your files, and take
some work off of your shoulders by once again,
using common sense, and chucking them into
the appropriate directories. The clutter is
now gone. Now of course, this workflow is not
as convenient as it could be. Yet. But just
imagine if this kind of useful tool could be
integrated deeper into the operating system,
and not have to work outside of it. That
would help us spend less and less time
on organizing things, and create or learn
something new instead. Love it. So good!
Fellow Scholars, what you are seeing here
is perhaps the birth of a new tool that
might become more useful than any other tool I
have ever seen. Wow. What a time to be alive!